[Música]
consigo una cita con nada más y nada
menos que tony robbins
para los que no saben quién es tony
robbins tony robbins es el gurú máximo
el mayor exponente a nivel mundial
hoy en día en temas de liderazgo la
revista fortune
le sacó un artículo y una portada y lo
llamó de sí
whisperer el hombre que le habla al oído
a los tíos a los gerentes generales de
las empresas más grandes y más
importantes en el mundo
un hombre que inspira a miles y miles de
personas al año en sus talleres de
liderazgo van 10 y 15 mil personas por
taller
y yo consigo una cita para que me cuente
para que me explique los secretos cómo
se hace eso para ver si yo logro algo
parecido en mis talleres de liderazgo
fabuloso me subo en mi avión me voy a
verlo
pues paso mi inmigración paso mi
aeropuerto etcétera etcétera y me pasa
la cosa más extraña
saco mi teléfono cuando ya estoy
llegando a la salida para pedir mi über
y cuando a pachón
rock
me sale que sólo hay que ver cats y
google docs
yo voy a ver a tony robbins o sea hasta
la cita más importante de mi vida y con
cuál me subo
imaginemos que me pongo a pensar verdad
con cuál me subo déjame de cómo sería
esto si me subo en 1 bercut esto ya me
lo imagino ahora abro la puerta y
mire por favor voy donde tony robbins y
usted porque quiere ir para allá
y usted qué va a hacer ahí
y yo no mira apúrate vale quien no pero
y porque ustedes porque tienes tanta
prisa y bueno total que ahí vamos
peleando y el gato finalmente arranca y
por el camino de 100 sabes que estoy
cansado yo voy a dormir una siesta yo
voy donde toni joven sí pero eso a mí no
me importa
bueno algún día llegó
y cómo sería mi viaje con google docs
yo me lo imagino me me suba al carro y
merecida bienvenido y mueve la colita
verdad está bien contento de verme y le
digo voy donde tony robbins igual
arranca como un loco yo no para le un
segundito no tan rápido ten cuidado nos
vamos vamos a chocar
vas a gastar todo el combustible
espérate
pues entonces en este mundo ficticio
porque no he conseguido la cita con tony
robbins
aunque si les gusta suficiente la charla
y me aplauden y la hacen viral y qué sé
yo pues puede ser que me la dé
entonces en este mundo ficticio oral
esto que ustedes ustedes van a hacer su
proceso de selección van a contactar a
alguien tan buscando unos nuevos
colaboradores para su organización y
miren los candidatos que les aparecen
mayoritariamente son cats
hay uno que otros dos por ahí por en
general les llegan sus cats
cuál contrato
y a quienes estoy haciendo yo referencia
cuál es la analogía aquí de estos caps
nuestros famosos y bien satanizados
millenials
y que veo mucho por ahí verdad
personas no lo acaban de decir quieren
construir un mundo mejor
quieren contribuir son emprendedores son
inteligentes los estudios muestran que
son de las generaciones que en esta
época de la vida son de las más
capacitadas en el mundo las más
estudiadas
son personas que están en este momento o
ya están ocupando o están empezando a
ocupar las posiciones de liderazgo más
importante de las empresas y las
organizaciones
y yo quiero bueno tengo además no sólo
quiero tengo que contratarlos tengo que
contratar de estos pero necesito que
trabajen bien que trabajen agusto que
trabajen motivados conmigo
como lo logró
como logró esta famosa motivación
y ustedes pensarán que les voy a hablar
de un truco de magia
pero no es un truco de magia
la motivación
se genera con procesos ordenados y
estructurados no es arte de magia
y no que esté tranquilo no son los bucks
las mesas de pimpón y los masajes gratis
eso no es lo que realmente motiva a la
gente y por qué vamos a hablar de
motivación
según un estudio de gallup de más de 30
mil empleados en el mundo
mostró que el 87 por ciento de los
empleados dice no sentirse motivado en
su trabajo el 87 por ciento apenas el 13
por ciento de tu fuerza laboral se
considera motivada
por si fuera poco las personas motivadas
producen 40% más en productividad que
las no motivadas entonces tú tienes el
87 por ciento de tu fuerza laboral
trabajando al 60 por ciento de su
capacidad
tú te das cuenta el impacto que eso está
teniendo en los resultados de tu
organización de tu empresa es terrible
el tema de la motivación es en serio
tiene un impacto dramático en los
resultados de la organización entonces
yo les voy a hablar de cuatro grandes
motivadores que es lo que realmente
motiva a la gente
el primer motivador se llama propósito
a propósito quiere decir que las
personas conocen comprenden y aprecian
el propósito de la organización los
millenials son muy exigentes quieren
trabajar en una empresa que sientan que
contribuyen algo a un mundo mejor
quieren contribuir a un mundo mejor
quieren construir un mundo mejor
entonces quieren un propósito claro
ahora como haces tú esto como líder en
tu organización como asegura que ese
motivador de propósito se da
tienes que desarrollar tienes que
establecer un plan estratégico claro y
simple que todos conozcan y comprendan
el plan estratégico complicadísimo de
24.000 páginas 8 cartapacios negros y
números a 20 años no me sé no cuenta ese
no es ok claro y simple que todos
comprendan piensa si yo fuera mañana a
tu organización a tu empresa y agarro y
lanzó un quiz sorpresa y le digo a las
personas escríbanme las tres prioridades
estratégicas de este año o de este
periodo como me va a ir
a ver qué calificación le voy a poner
el segundo gran motivador se llama
contribución si ustedes piensan aquí en
este equipo desde los pits de la
fórmula1
qué nivel de claridad tendrán ellos de
su rol como se imaginan ustedes esto
ustedes se imaginan que uno diga lo otro
mira tú traes las llantas no quién era
el de las llantas
no si fulano así es verdad miren el
taladro este como cómo que funciona en
cuéntame un segundito aunque ya voy
ustedes creen que podrían cambiar las
cuatro llantas en menos de tres segundos
como lo hacen hoy en día por supuesto
que no sería imposible
estas personas conocen perfectamente qué
se espera de ellas cuál es su trabajo y
cómo eso contribuye al propósito
entonces contribuciones que las personas
conocen qué se espera de ellas y cómo su
trabajo va a contribuir al propósito de
la organización esto es bien importante
porque por definición implica que si no
hay un plan estratégico claro y simple
es decir el propósito no está claro no
se puede dar el motivador de
contribución
porque no sé con qué contribuyo
qué vas a hacer tú para lograrlo yo les
dije que esto es un tema de procesos
esta es toda la parte donde tú vas a
fijar objetivos
formalmente a cada una de las personas
donde tú vas a trabajar en conjunto a
desarrollar los planes de acción para
que esos objetivos se cumplan donde tú
le vas a dar un seguimiento ordenado
estructurado sistemático y riguroso al
cumplimiento de eso
donde tú vas a reconocer y recompensar a
las personas que lo hacen bien que hacen
bien su trabajo que cumplen que se
comportan bien pero de esas cosas que en
todas las citas inspiradoras del
liderazgo no se dice pero tienes que
hacer como líder tiene que castigar
también a los que no cumplen
tienes que castigar a los que no cumplen
adecuadamente
cuál es el tercer motivador
el tercer motivador se llama superación
qué quiere decir superación superación
quiere decir que las personas ven que
alguien se ocupa de su desarrollo y que
tienen la oportunidad de crecer aprender
y superarse en la organización
los millennials algunos de estos que
hemos visto por ahí están en la
entrevista de trabajo y te preguntan a
mí cuando me van a promover
pero pero sin este contratado pero yo
quiero saber de una vez por si acaso
y me da igual tener capacitación con qué
frecuencia y voy a tener un coach y un
mentor
y los señores ya grandes como yo así
como pero bueno si no te contratado si
bueno porque quiero saber antes por si
acaso entonces la gente quiere si quiere
crecer aprender y superarse si se le da
la oportunidad
qué tienes que hacer tú cuál es el
proceso este es todo el proceso que se
llama de desarrollo donde tú vas a
evaluar a las personas
vas a determinar qué cosas necesitas que
tiene que aprender qué habilidades tiene
que aprender qué habilidades tiene que
desarrollar para ir mejorando su
desempeño hacer su trabajo ir creciendo
superarse poder optar a esas posiciones
de más responsabilidad que quiere tienes
que darle un seguimiento también
ordenado estructurado a esto yo
recomiendo que te reúnas por lo menos
una vez al mes mínimo una vez al mes con
cada uno de tus deportes directos para
hablar de su desarrollo de si está
aprendiendo lo que tiene que aprender de
qué actividades de aprendizaje le vamos
a asignar y no es sólo mandarlo a cursos
y tú tienes que aprender como líder a
hacer coaching y mentoría para llevarlos
en este proceso
y el cuarto motivador que muchos
confunden como el primer motivador se
llama pertenencia
qué quiere decir pertenencia que las
personas sienten que son apreciadas y
valoradas por sus jefes y compañeros y
que tienen la oportunidad que las
condiciones están dadas para dar lo
mejor de sí
pero antes de hablar del proceso les voy
a hablar de un comportamiento
fundamental para que se dé la
pertenencia y de un comportamiento
fundamental de liderazgo y es el trato
cordial y respetuoso con todo el mundo
en todo momento
yo no sé qué ha pasado que hay personas
que creen que porque están en posiciones
de liderazgo y digo esta frase porque
posición de liderazgo y líder no es
igual
y creen que eso les permite tratar mal a
las personas
y un líder no trata mal a las personas
nunca las ofenden nunca es grosero y
nunca descalifica las puede regañar les
puede expresar claramente estoy
descontento con tu trabajo por abc y si
no lo arreglas vas a tener serios
problemas pero no hay necesidad de
utilizar malas palabras e insultos y
descalificativos cordial y respetuoso
siempre buenos días por favor gracias
ok cuál es el proceso qué es lo que
tienes que hacer tú la parte de
pertenencia es la parte de tener
condiciones y herramientas de trabajo
adecuadas
que tu oficina está adecuada que si
trabaja en una computadora tiene una
computadora adecuada y en buenas
condiciones no todo el mundo necesita la
computadora con una pantalla de 40
pulgadas no pero su computadora adecuada
y funciona en la silla la oficina el
escritorio el aire acondicionado la
iluminación el camión el cuchillo el
desarmador el montacargas el tractor
están en condiciones acordes a lo que el
negocio necesita es imposible estar
motivado si mi equipo de trabajo no
funciona
ahora
esto que les estoy contando esto no lo
leí en un libro
esto funciona en la vida real
yo lo he aplicado en las empresas que yo
he manejado y les voy a dar ejemplos
yo fui yo en una empresa que se llama
lafarge en méxico las fallas la empresa
cementera más grande del mundo y yo
manejé la operación de mexico yo fui yo
aquí en guatemala que ustedes conocen un
poquito más de cementos progreso durante
un poquito más de cinco años y esta
metodología te va a llevar a ti a tu
organización a ganar a ganar el juego a
ganar la competencia y por supuesto que
si es una empresa a ganar más dinero
entonces qué resultados nos dio a
nosotros
una de las cosas que yo veo muy fuerte
cuando manejo empresas y sobre todo
empresas industriales es el tema de la
seguridad la salud y la seguridad
ocupacional los accidentes
nosotros cuando empezamos en mexico en
este viaje nosotros tomamos una empresa
que tenía 12 accidentes al año y la
llevamos a cero en dos años cero
accidentes en mexico no es suiza
y la mantuvimos en cero accidentes los
tres años que yo seguí como si yo y
después yo me vine para guatemala y
viene un nuevo vídeo y pasaron tres años
sin accidentes más
en el caso de cementos progreso que una
empresa un poco más grande con tres mil
500 colaboradores nosotros empezamos con
más de 100 accidentes al año 100
personas se lesionaban todos los años
y nosotros en cinco años lo reducimos a
seis sólo seis accidentes
y accidentes todos menores
machu con de dedo y cosas así ningún
accidente serio qué pasó con los
resultados económicos en el caso de las
fans méxico nosotros pasamos
cuadruplicamos la venta y la utilidad
neta en cinco años lo multiplicamos por
cuatro
lo multiplicamos por 4 en el caso de
cementos progreso en 5 años el mercado
del cemento no creció en guatemala no
creció el mercado se quedó estancado y
nosotros aumentamos la rentabilidad la
utilidad en 80 por ciento en 5 años sin
aumento en el volumen de ventas
y otro medidor importante para mí el
clima laboral en el caso de méxico lo
medimos con un consultor externo y
creció enormemente en el caso de
cementos progreso utilizamos la
organización great place to work que
mide el clima laboral en las empresas y
sacó un ranking y nosotros en tres años
pasamos de no haber calificado en el
ranking nuestra calificación fue tan
baja que no aparecimos a ser la número
uno para centroamérica y el caribe
entonces si se puede si funciona
esto es una metodología que funciona son
procesos ordenados para asegurar que tu
gente está altamente motivada y produce
resultados excepcionales entonces qué
esperan que están esperando ustedes qué
necesitas para ponerte a trabajar a
implementar estos procesos y tener gente
motivada e inspirada no importa de qué
generación es que entregue resultados
excepcionales imaginemos un mundo
donde el 80% de los colaboradores dicen
estoy motivado vengo a trabajar con
ganas y con gusto
no les voy a hacer el ejercicio de que
se paren los que no están motivados
porque algunos vinieron con su jefe
y para cerrar
imaginen
que nosotros llevamos esto que nosotros
llevamos a esta metodología y generamos
colaboradores altamente motivados
entregando resultados excepcionales en
todas nuestras instituciones públicas y
de gobierno
cómo sería ese mundo
muchas gracias
[Música]